I remember I had Marianne Williamson on
my show and I told her you know I really
don't watch the news and she goes that's
you need to watch the news like you need
to be informed especially as like a
white male you need to know what's
happening in the world maybe but you can
get the news from different places I
don't need to watch the TV to get the
news I can check you know Apple news or
whatever or get someone to tweet me
something and check it out and people
got to tell you the news no matter what
right yeah can't really escape the news
I try to focus on I truly believe that
when I focus on giving to people and
service I'm a happy human being and and
research is backed science of happiness
that when you're in contribution to
someone else whether it's opening the
door buying a coffee having a
conversation listening to someone when
they're going through something doing
charity work whatever maybe that makes
you the happiest when we're giving to
others I don't want to do straight-up
politics with victory I did not get an
essay book of the things that you won't
talk about but I don't want to do
politics I think it's a good escape this
is meta politics and way worse but in a
time like we live in right now where
politics seems crazy everyone's trying
to destroy each other all of those
things do you have any tricks that you
use for yourself or that you've
recommended to other people to scale
back I mean one of the things on your
eye to show people is that your
worldview just can't be political yeah
you know if your worldview is just
politics you're always doing this you've
got blinders on and you need a much
bigger philosophical religious whatever
it is whatever your worldview is it
needs to be much wider do you have any
tricks because it seems like everyone
everywhere you know and I know I'm sort
of self-selected into the future when
anyone sees me at the store they want to
talk politics sure but but I do sense
people it's making people crazier it's
making people angry er you know they
just released this big study about how
depressed people are right now and I I
remember when I started being an
entrepreneur after leaving my brothers I
paid 250 a month for my brother's place
to have a room from his place right I
started making enough money
get an apartment for four ninety-five a
month it was the scariest thing to write
a check for for 95 because I was like I
don't know how I'm gonna pay this next
month but I got the cheapest apartment I
could in Columbus Ohio and I remember
and I never car at the time so I was
walking everywhere and I remember saying
to myself I'm not gonna get a TV in the
first few years I didn't have a TV and I
just focused on my mission in my vision
which was creation which was getting
customers and sales and adding value to
those customers and clients and not
having a TV was a big blessing I love
movies and I love TV so I would go to
the movies all the time but I wouldn't
allow myself to browse and see chaos on
a screen until midnight and then go to
sleep with nightmares from the chaos so
personally I tried to I remember had
Marianne Williamson on my show and I
told her you know I really don't watch
the news and she goes that's you need to
watch the news like you need to be
informed especially as like a white male
you need to know what's happening in the
world maybe but you can get the news
from different places I don't need to
watch the TV to get the news I can check
you know Apple news or whatever or get
someone to tweet me something and check
it out and people gonna tell you the
news no matter what right you can't
really escape I try to focus on I truly
believe that when I focus on giving to
people and service I'm a happy human
being and and research is backed science
of happiness that when you're in
contribution to someone else whether
it's opening the door buying a coffee
having a conversation listening to
someone when they're going through
something doing charity work whatever
maybe that makes you the happiest when
we're giving to others so we're focused
on self and what we don't have suffering
is the result of obsessive self centric
thinking so when I'm thinking in the
news this is not working in my favor I
need to this is an outrage or I'm not
happy about this because it's not
helping me you're gonna be unhappy and
I'm not saying you shouldn't fight for
what you want in and have things to
change sure but if you're gonna be if
you want to be happier focus on other
people focus on service and also don't
watch the news and as media companies
ourself we
watch us but I think watch focus on
things that bring you joy I think as
adults we don't play enough you know in
my in my studio I got a frisbee and I'll
and we'd love to work hard you know our
team works hard but I'll grab mat or
CeeLo and my friend and I say we need
five minutes just to throw the frisbee
like we need to play who plays anymore
especially if you can't go outside you
can't do this who's playing well I'm
chasing a one-year-old dog exactly right
that yeah but I'm like a big advocate of
play over watching TV go do something
fun I went out to was a I've been in a
leaf or eight years how long you been
here about eight years eight years
literally two days ago the first time I
went to Franklin Canyon Lake or park
have you been in this place I don't even
know what that is this is ten minutes
from here
it's a lake and nature of like 100 acres
in the middle of a lame you can't see
the city it's literally in the middle of
Mulholland Drive never heard of this
place it's unbelievable I saw a photo of
an audience we got a lake then we got a
lake and like ducks and turtles and
everything and I went there on Sunday
with my girlfriend and our dog it was
just like we're in nature we're hanging
out I'm not watching TV I'm not on
social media I'm a big salsa dancer
I love slowly for 15 years of my salsa
dancing around the world I play guitar I
like to play sports workout I'm just
like go do something that's going to
contribute and benefit your life and
contribute and benefit someone else's
life when you do those things you're
gonna be a better person I'm learning
Spanish I'm trying all these different
things that give me away from the train
wreck of the news so that did I
recommend don't assess yourself into
what's not working for you go be the
change do you sense that right now
because of Corona protests because
everything is is so seemingly chaotic
that people are becoming more receptive
to the type of stuff you're talking
about because I can just for me like I
started gardening I started doing this
so I'll show you when we get at it we
got a ton of we're growing a ton of
great stuff carrots man I got real
carrots I got I got tomatoes I got
cucumbers I got zucchini I got broccoli
peppers
started doing that I'm cooking a lot
more David usually cooks a ton but now
I'm barbecuing all the time and like I'm
refining some skills and like I think
there's a unique opportunity in this
mess to either come out of it more
skilled more refined more passionate
about what you do or maybe realize that
what you were doing before isn't what
you want to do or all that stuff yeah
versus some people that I think are just
gonna have slogged through it and not
really thought about their life
critically enough and then they'll just
be on the other side and the world would
be different and I'm on both sides here
I if you if you need to take a pause and
rest for these last three months
because you've been go go go go go none
stop for ten years and you've never
taken a pause in your life this is the
most beautiful time for you to sit
around and do nothing and read a book
and lounge and not hustle so for some
people I think that is what you need and
personally my philosophy is I feel like
this is what the world needed in general
is for us to take a pause with
technology being so fast with us on
social media most people on their phones
six seven eight hours a day and a lot of
social media it's like what are we
consuming our time with it's not what
we're supposed to be doing all day
pretty sure it's not making us happier
it's nothing us happier it's making us
more neurotic if like I need more likes
anymore followers I mean what's
happening in the news it's just it's
craziness and so for some I think don't
do anything and that's what you need you
need to reevaluate why your life isn't
working why this relation I'm seeing so
many people I'm not sure if you're
seeing this a lot of big personalities
are posting we're getting a divorce
we're going through breakup you're
finally evaluating your relationship
you're trapped in houses soon every
minute three months you can't do it oh I
like this guy you can't escape anymore
so I think people are getting clear on
what they want yeah cuz they haven't
been clear for a long time maybe partly
but not fully so for some people you
need a pause you need a break you need
to evaluate you need to take inventory
of everything in your life and create a
new game plan moving forward you need to
find some coaches and mentors and have a
game plan and go take action for other
people I'm kind of in the middle I feel
like I've hustled more my business I've
hired more people I've been like more
creative than ever but I'm also going to
the
park and relaxing with my girlfriend my
dog and the weekends which I would never
do and I'm taking that time to be in
nature so I feel like I'm trying to do
both and bounce my personal life but
then work going kind of all in and
getting clear or like what is our
audience need right now what does our
customers need where do they need for
the next five to ten years if this
doesn't change so I'm a little in the
middle and I have empathy for both sides
but I think if you can rediscover what
you want to do in your life and who you
want to become whether you take action
on it now or just discover it now that's
what should be doing how do you decide
how much stuff to put out there in the
midst of all this because a lot of what
you're talking about is to ease up on
this stuff go live your life get out
there in nature etc etc I think I
mentioned to you last time like people
say to me Dave why don't you do an
interview every day do five interviews a
week do seven interviews a week and we
do one or two and I can obviously do
some other stuff yeah and I it's not for
a lack of time but it really in many
ways is for a respect of my audience
people stop yeah like it's because I
it's like if you listen to me then
hopefully you listen to one of your
episodes maybe you listen to Sam Harris
or Joe Rogan or whatever it's like I
want you to that that's great if you
give a couple hours a week to this stuff
that's fantastic but I don't want you to
give 40 hours of your week so I don't
even want you to give 20 hours of your
week to new to this so like I think it's
important what we're doing it's valuable
what we're doing yeah but how do you
decide like what's enough and what's too
much I look at are the three factors one
is like what is my audience what I think
my audience wants and my intuitive side
of what I think they're gonna want or
need what works for me
personally liked I don't wanna be on
every day doing any of you either it's
it's a lot of energy what personally
works for my life my lifestyle my vision
for the future and there was a day to
say if you'd like to be inspired
motivated and educated by some of the
most successful people around the world
check out the school of greatness full
episode playlist right over here and if
you'd like to see Lois houses interview
with me click right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell